[Music]
general grievances alright guys put the
phones away please
where's fire team ever episode this is
why we're the work ain't all poured our
try - all right so where's fire team
ever episode seven here we are all right
guys it's hot
I mean eight you're correct so hey so
real quick let's let's start with
grievances remember it's all loved but
let's just air our grievances what I
mean well problems we have we're talking
about it I'll start kkd whoring she will
shoot should we all look up Arkady's no
we know that his is gonna be the best
dude he got so mad one night what night
no we saw you playing with these other
people those trials yeah well I was
great Vincennes let's talk let's talk
about it because this one of my biggest
pet peeves no one of my biggest pet
peeves will Steve is recently Steve will
send me messages through Xbox we got
this whole group chat right right
Steve's never on the group chat but I'll
hear from Steve he'll send me a message
through Xbox oh I see I see your I see
your play know someone else huh you know
kind of throw and slide light but you're
offline so we know that's my Grievous
with Steve is that you don't even know
when he's on you like we're already in a
party yeah in this [ __ ] I've
sent a party invite invite everybody
yeah
just join our party let's hurry I don't
get a party invite from Steve okay enjoy
myself cuz when I was online I noticed I
don't know it's because of this podcast
but random people from that world okay
would be I got a good message message
you know just random people just hitting
me up like it's all part of the fame
Stevie I'm on the road in people you
know another grievance I have with your
ass okay I'm on the road doing stand-up
you know and people coming up to me like
hey bro I'm being known for being on the
what happened at the Comedy Store some
you would to see you're in my house my
favorite is you kept yelling at me for
not following you on Instagram and then
I looked on my Instagram I was like oh
yeah I I do follow you one of the og
originals yeah we meet you and Bob okay
myself
but now I'm in one so you got the door
you have the dorm room and you made a
choice to get a dog a piano and a girl
he brings a girl breathing and it's
crazy when he's trying to play like
before he would play and then you'd be
like you just can't whisper laughs two
hours on Sundays Sunday came you could
even talk Sunday came and we were
looking forward to playing with you and
then you you know you had to go to the
horror Ville over here part of the
reason why it's kind of change for me is
my girl noticed that when I play
specifically PvP like my energy changes
it's not even your fault this is like I
get mad oh and she goes she doesn't like
it when I get okay but you play but you
get mad I don't get mad because I got
when you'd that when you're playing okay
so I don't play against other people I
do I do like Ultimate Team you know what
I mean it's like you know whatever
problem here's but here's the question
here's the question Steve how how much
PvP did we play destiny 1
I didn't play till the end but that's
all we did that's that's all we did and
do you do you like it that you enjoy I
love it that's all that matters and
that's where you got to relate
we have a solution she says you're not
in the hot seat if you can't play in
your own apartment
even when you go over there we're gonna
work it out is it because I I think it's
twofold issue either a tight space and
it's like it's distracting and annoying
to her when you're playing which is
valid that's what it is or or it could
be the thing where it's like hey you're
giving that attention what about me that
could be an issue too how do you guys
deal with that solution
[Laughter]
Steve here's the thing we talked about
it right we have a promise Steve you
have a promissory note right okay you're
gonna come over right the only thing we
want from you is a promise that you'll
do it we were disappointed because there
should be repercussions if he doesn't do
it the promise there's you know what be
fun because like we'll be like doing
better PvP cuz I'll actually see his
movements and be like no no you fussing
a Craig oh now I hear Craig over here is
mister power mo now always talking about
no no no no I don't with in two days
Fortuna this dude's camp for heavy more
than than he ever did for no dude not
more than great let me let me tell you
let me tell you this was the other day I
spawned right next to to Craig right
there's 45 seconds on the heavy ammo 45
seconds to wait not only that he's
sitting there so like let's say the
power n Mo's back here right he's facing
out does he put up a shield shield
shield on Berkey for 45 seconds
we're out here dying on the Craig guy at
the raid rocket which I just got the
raid rocket launcher and so I wanted to
practice with it yeah and also practice
with you get it you dishonorable
[ __ ] I don't know as a drop I'm
defending here thank you let me just say
my last piece by the way the reason this
guy gets angry is cuz he goes for it we
go for it at the same time I'm putting
up your shield to him no no no no my
favorite move is to use my fists of hat
no you use my shoulder charge to hit
coke out of the way yeah he's done well
here's here's here's my deal I'm
constantly moving I'm not gonna sit
there in verse 10 seconds I may wait if
my team's all there but 45 [ __ ] I
agreed I was forty nights he was
hardened and we're gonna get his
argument is to practice with it
it's a [ __ ] rocket launcher all
rocket launchers work the same somebody
you shoot it mr. Baum bombs don't even
work you know why that okay so now okay
fair enough fair enough I was being a
dick but I only did it this week it
wasn't like I've been doing it since the
day one Sam John don't worthy spawn
to be honest I don't even know where the
heaviest
I won't go up on the map there they
change okay I got agreements let's go
into this Kady whoring Oh cuz I started
with it whoa you're trying to move it on
him now yeah we shortened brief I'm
gonna shut this [ __ ] down this new rival
there's no dispute that coke he's a lot
he reminds us every day not that we need
to disagree yeah well you have to hear
about it yeah I'm just proud I'm just
like you know if he was like a you know
like a pennant winner for the you know
like baseball he be every day guess what
I want a pennant floyd mayweather of are
ya know wfe yeah we're the worst fire
team ever well he's the best on the
worst so so that being said but so the
thing is when I play I play for fun I'm
going to have fun my friends I wanted
sometimes I want to do well I give us
trials or competitive house tonight yes
yes but but if it's if it's like one of
those I want to put my best foot forward
but the rest of time I'm having fun this
guy treats it like you know if if his
Katy drops point zero-zero get 1% it's
like you [ __ ] like I used to be
in a 2.79 12 you know I know if you
don't try it's not like sometimes I feel
like which moves us to Frank I had had
to have the talk with Frank about taking
it a little more serious you know cuz we
have this podcast we're trying to do and
Frank's on there [ __ ] take it hits of
a bong during the gameplay order and
Thai food with his girlfriend you know
just out of nowhere would you make fun
of my mom
we gotta hear Snoop Dogg [ __ ] but it's a
French credit he said okay get the coat
I must speak because you don't want to
get on you right now because he's very
competitive this we're doing trials your
ass is standing there and all we hear
all we hear in the background is like
okay okay so let me let me hear let me
hear this we're trying to win trials
fair enough fair enough let me let me
let me defend myself a little bit okay
so this this is my my thought process so
like when I'm when we're playing
casually to have fun
I don't harp that much when we're doing
like quick play but that's why I'd like
to do a quick play cuz quick play even
if I die even if I'm getting [ __ ] up
right because everybody's not playing
good and I'm getting [ __ ] up I don't I
don't complain at least I get to revive
and keep shooting right don't [ __ ] I
hate playing like countdown and playing
with people that are dying and then I
just die and then or I die if I die
first
and then I got to sit there and wait
even when I make mistakes well it's not
even that I just want to be going like
if you guys watch me play I'm constantly
[ __ ] moving so I hate I hate waiting
the whole time and then I hate doing a
trials card where you know well we got
to reset the card and we played the same
map over and over and over so late I'm
competitive when it comes to trials cuz
I won't get that [ __ ] done I want to go
through and I want I want everybody to
be honed in and taking it serious so we
can get the [ __ ] done because if you
don't take it seriously in trials you're
not gonna get notes that's what we're
doing it more you know but I agree with
trials I'm talking about the rest of the
like I mean literally we could be
playing like the lamest game-mode it'll
be supremacy which I hate and gonna be
like why aren't you
my Katie's positive I don't care Felix
I'm tired of hexagon caching and [ __ ]
[ __ ] no this is one because you're
talking about supremacy I'll tell you
what it's about supremacy because it all
started when supremacy what oh no he's
not he's not no no I'm about to I'm
about to break this [ __ ] down supremacy
this is where it started because I think
I had like a KD like 7.0 got all these
kills [ __ ] buddy but it was supremacy
it was supremacy right yeah so Craig
made a little comment about Oh coke
didn't pick up any cress so this is this
is what driving me [ __ ] nuts but that
is annoying because that's the game man
listen listen that's what you don't know
you guys are fixated on you got to pick
up the crest that's true but what
creates kress kills kills if I'm sitting
over here with 22 kills Craig's got
three [ __ ] kills and he's got all the
new who killed all the people for him to
pick up the crest is it harder to kill a
person or go run pick up a crest kill
it's harder to kill people you need to
get kills in order not only that okay he
says KD doesn't yep he says KD he says
KD doesn't matter in supremacy the thing
is when you die what do you drop you
drop a crest used to you know give the
crest two things okay never onto coke
overplaying control these ghosts of
control like I hate to see your thing
says zero okay but I get I don't care I
won't go and I'll defend code on that
because it's like earn cuz you'll run
bastard what else is all we got
I'm like I'll run you know and if
someone else if I see two guys already
if something 1.00 yeah I'm poor I'm
point eighty he's uh point six zero
point two five because I just don't care
your point what cokes in there I want to
do that point but but the control they
they all have they all have their hold
on line they all have their their
aspects yeah you got to get you got to
get zones but the thing is you don't get
points with the zones if you don't get
kills yeah if you get a negative Kady
you're losing your team points and
you're giving them points Kady has a big
part to deal with every game how about
Willie just when we spawn on the first
one I would hate when he would run right
past yeah I get that cuz I know first I
know people are gonna get the first one
but if we're both rushing B then that
pushes them off what I like to do is I
like to swing all the way around and get
a our famous for famous big fight Evers
Steven Steven Franco I got so mad at you
during control member because was I
wasn't killing anybody no no because you
weren't getting you the zone yeah yeah
and then the next time oh my god Steve
it was my now it's gone down a little
Steve here's the thing Steve's better
but also you can remember it also
factors as much of you play so if you
play more and you play more competitive
than you know it goes up and down
I beat Griffin by 0.6 Craig but I mean
also that's a I don't play so it goes
Eric Steve me Griffin Craig no no it's
right Griffin Oh Craig Griffin oh yeah
smaller lighter me and Griffin play a
lot I think a lot more than Frank
so of course our KD is balanced by how
much we play and how much we win or lose
I play a lot okay under Steve so me and
Craig and I haven't got anything to
verify this but we're like we know
Steve's on and he's not playing with us
and we don't know if because Steve has
this weird thing where he wants to play
the story himself and he he wants to
love luck because he doesn't want to be
the lowest level yeah he fails you'll
join you and there you can't even Steve
[Music]
disappears but we try to tell Steve like
you're gonna get higher quicker if
you're playing with the group playing by
yourself you're gonna steal and rewards
man the last episode yeah no but the
clan episodes are kind of nice cause
like you don't have to necessarily like
we finished the raid the clan got
rewards for the season weakly there's
weekly tasks there's nine for the season
yeah we maxed it we have a pretty big
clan though there's a lot of other
people friends I don't know half them
all these names that's why I do notice
that but listen listen that's why I
didn't want our clan to be worse fire
team ever because we get rewards based
off what everybody does and if we had
just us in a clan we wouldn't level our
clan up yeah all the way you know what
I'm saying though I mean in a sense I
still want to get reverse clan like most
of those people I don't even play and
we're getting credit for it so like cuz
I only play with you guys and then
meskhi how'd you find these guys who are
they I made I made mesh key and Daffy
admins so they they just so I mean
that's partly the reason to to be honest
because I don't have these
we don't play with them don't play with
them in the clan yeah there while
they're doing [ __ ] we're getting
experience for it
we don't spy now look and I'll know they
comes out and I know you don't like some
beer like arty with randoms yeah - and
but I already know you guys already have
a set team like four dudes well I'm one
line quick play it on my god he'll jump
out we jump out to play with our team
yeah our people if we know it like
here's the thing if you were online and
we saw your online if we're playing with
two randoms as soon as that game's over
boom we just do a Kickstarter for a
monthly Kickstarter he's got a patreon
no but I have the space and we can do
the sugar mama out there any sugar mama
but I'll hook it up in my place I will
say there there are people in the clan
though that like that we do play with
quite a bit like meskhi GAF someone that
I want to cross clamming and and a newer
guy ghost ghost Lupo because he actually
him and his guys hunk got dike Pikachu I
need two hours of Sunday sampling a good
shooter so when you get fun to do we got
a war when you get that when you get
thank you doing
I lead to the first part when you get
that when you get that raid Ingram from
Hawthorne or whatever it's only like
level 10 you got to upgrade it when you
do those when you do the raid though you
get high you get higher drops alright so
you get that I mean it goes bro yeah
yeah and honestly the raids not it's not
heart wave you do with people that know
what they're doing
I've done a few of the things we got
through it in two hours fun like we did
but yeah it's a lot of like it's a lot
of like puzzles and talking and like
that one thing we do the guys are
running around to start the dolly I
gotta tell you which ones to shoot so
our last episode six was our raid
footage from the first attempt we did
which sadly Frank wasn't there but the
rest of us were it was painful because I
realized I'm Tara that's the thing about
[ __ ] no we did the radio Frank
wasn't there of course half the time
Frank's out doing a show and where were
you yesterday San Marcos Haley I was in
similar it Frank's all over the place
but I was just going back to it was so
painful
you were leaving I was leading you and
it was it was hard because I realized
like I was reading a website that was
giving me terrible directions on how to
do that rate my imagine terrible
directions push me yeah plus year is the
word I'm out no so like I was terrible
the raid was there but it's like that
was a thing as like so when you play
with these guys and they know what
they're doing yeah it changed up so when
I looked back that was also the thing
that people don't know is that they
won't know is like we just started that
that rate had just come out yeah we
wanted to play it what's it called
Leviathan Leviathan and we were on like
the dolphin which the dogs is a hard map
because how do you do that thing well
you have to know the sections these guys
call it r1 r3 oh yeah they got code and
they know where the thing that when you
okay one thing I noticed though Steve
when you play with people there is a
there is a moment of like would you have
to take time
to hear how they do it you know because
because they have everybody like on the
gauntlets yeah I've seen two different
people with two different ways they do
it like some people call like they call
out there like number like top bottom or
somebody else calls out like just a one
of you shouldn't hit yeah that's what we
did that works bad yeah it's like
everybody it's a lot of like just like
listening and like okay what do you want
what do you want us to do it's just
Craig's horrible it but what what what I
do like don't like absolutely when we
did it with ghosts they did a good job
of explaining even like they did do that
what happens during that that missioner
like that yeah well like whoa we were
talking about the gauntlet because I was
I was worried about it because they're
shooting they're like they're like okay
Craig Pete sue you guys don't really new
were runners they're like no they may be
in the runners I thought the runners
were like because I had never done it so
I thought that was the hardest part I'm
like just had a good idea and then I
found out it was literally just running
and calling out whatever we did it it's
not my question is we didn't clear those
planets the better so hive on the moon
yeah you know like what is there now
we've just left like all the Guardians
are like good luck moon yeah no that
stuff still happening there I want to I
want to be able to do those rooms
hopefully they'll bring it back I'm sure
they will they're bringing back guns
next season they better step it okay
they're bringing back to listo cuz they
already get rid of all these they're
getting they're bringing like the moon
is still there that's the thing like
they're gonna build up open it up we'll
but it's just you know yeah but they
will I mean that's what they did what
you know the first one it took a long
time and they built it up now I think
we're getting close toward the end we
got about 15 minutes ish so I wanted to
talk about basically I thought let's
talk about what got the last great game
like or the first great game that got
you like really into gaming like I just
want to start all right well for me like
I got it I mean you know hobbies long
yeah donkey gone no like I gotta say
like the I got out of gaming and then in
college my buddy introduced me back into
Goldeneye and that Goldeneye
that sucked me because I would only play
it on super hard yeah but it was a great
game and that was like one of the first
first-person yeah well I think that was
console devices person to my sister
Carol ruined me and my cousins like we
would get into fistfights that ruined
relationships because that was how all
of our cousins established the hierarchy
who was the coolest was who could wreck
at [ __ ] Goldeneye Goldeneye was great
man it just it was a it was really
brought that was like a fun thing but it
wasn't online you had to play four
people in a room for me it was Gears of
War here's the wars that will gain that
I the first time I started like actually
wasn't the entire people Gears of War
with someone and then they ruined it
with Gears of War two because they
opened up like how many slots for is
perfect yeah or before for like when you
have a group of four you could talk over
each other you can hear everything once
it went to like five six it's out is
over it's like you know when you're
going like one of arrows groups we love
you era but Dad you got talking you know
but like four was a thing so that was
the first time I was like that I
realized it brought a level of enjoyment
to the game that like without it like I
wouldn't play destiny if there wasn't
talking to people and playing like the
we do that wouldn't played a
communication especially destiny war
like the story was all fractured and you
don't know what the [ __ ] was going on
know the core of it is like being able
to play with people so that's the first
time I was like oh this is actually fun
then I started playing like you know
sports I like playing sports games
online but but mostly that Gears of War
was the one that got me in there like
hallo for me let's go hallo was the big
big one I remember I was like at my
aunt's house I went to like Blockbuster
and I was like oh this is cool cuz when
the Xbox first came out and I rented it
and I remember playing it and I made my
cousin who's a who's a girl I made her
play as the second character and we
played through that whole [ __ ] story
line just in that one night and it was
just I just remember playing it in just
being addicted to it because there's
such a good story the pistol with the
sniper scope on it the worst the first
pistol yeah three headshot from like a
mile
dude bro Kim gun halo 2 came out and I
was working on a TV shows as years ago
and I don't want to name the show cuz it
dates me but Dukes of Hazzard Hazzard
number but Dave the grips had put three
Xboxes in the trailer and we were into
their truck and we would go in there
lunch and just halo 2 we would have like
all the people like forums those were
the fun days when you whole and partly
the swings like the bit connect your
Xboxes oh yeah first person shooters oh
wait so anyway so yours was halo okay
Steve go ahead woman Shadow the Colossus
that's amazing one of mine was ICO which
was the game before that by the same
Sony and that was just amazing and then
um [ __ ] all the fallouts follow the
phones for bioshock's first game [ __ ]
all the grand theft [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
the bio was real fun shotgun over to
pare it down to 100 Sasson screeds first
one I think there's so many red dead
redemption i [ __ ] love that but pare
it down to one like what's the one game
that like really like sucked you into
gaming that's like you Skyrim [ __ ] me
up yeah dude I bought the remastered
edition I had to return it cuz I was
like I
living a life
you're like my knee you were like mining
and [ __ ] iron bobbies are born at Oh
Bobby was like well Jordan got worried
about Jordan got Bob into it yeah the
more Owen yeah just imagine that Jordan
got Bobby do you really the first time
the dragon comes down just like what so
the first game I mean I was super young
but it was on a Super Nintendo a little
bad well my first game that got me in
the game fight or two remember you have
to go the arcade to put the quarter in
that was Street Fighter
yes Dragon's Lair oh yeah that was there
yeah I was way too young Street tempest
I could just go on no but I think the
game Steve how old gal I'm just kidding
I was there was that was the fun that
was a heydays was going to the arcades I
got when you see it in movies I kind of
missed those like stranger things
yeah they arcade like the arcade the
place you could go talk to arcades like
blockbuster now on yes well we have a
better arcade just in where you live now
they have arcade arcade bar so yeah I we
have a couple of Milwaukee and they're
pretty it's competitive
well they got they have you ever played
the pac-man tables my stepdad that was
my stepdad side business my stepdad had
a bunch of hard cave games and he'd
switch I'm at a different restaurants
but what growing in high school we just
had arcade yeah we had arcade games just
in my garage and my friends would just
come over and be like what you guys got
[ __ ] arcade games which
there was a Crotty game do you remember
I had two joysticks
yes yes that was the karate champ Crotty
champ member track you feel yeah yeah
yeah we're track and field people used
to put like a pencil you guys remember
this because you like member the first
Nintendo because I remember contra and
Megaman Tecmo Bowl oh you had Tecmo Bowl
well I just going back to one favorite
time I go was the first game on ps2 that
I play I want to tell you because you
like you know shadow shadow well I co
was the first game they did and when I
played it I was like oh man this is
gonna be amazing this generation of
gaming like this is gonna be and I
thought like all games are gonna feel
like this because it's a beautiful game
it's it's a look there's no talking it's
all just kind of like character-driven
but it's done through emotion like
emotes and and then when it ended like I
was like I was so excited for games like
that but it was really that one
developer it was that one guy who that
one main guy I think his name is you ADA
he did like I go shadow and trico or
wood glass Guardian those games are
amazing they're beautiful there are like
what got me like cuz I went from playing
all types of games even back like when I
was younger I'd play like Baldur's Gate
like because I play it once PlayStation
came out and I played Final Fantasy 7 I
was into RPGs yeah that's all I did
yeah so like on computer and stuff like
that but then like lady said when Xbox
dropped and my dad got it for me opening
day and got me halo after halo versus
juniors that was what was he'll early
2000 it was the first yeah it was for
the first it was the platform game for
the XP it was like really the first time
I really what Bungie's destiny I don't
know I got I heard it through you guys
because it was dated a good ad campaign
I thought
did a good push and I was like oh let me
check this game out I remember getting
into it and talking to you about it like
when I first started working at the
store and I was just like hey I'm
getting into this and I was like yeah I
was trying to talk to you about like
motes of light and you're like you know
you need to learn more know what what
rights are and yeah I play with you
level 20 most of you here that was just
you trying too hard these guys talk
about
I never asked over but that's what you
were saying see I give I give my super
competitive nature cuz I was a Call of
Duty guy so I was all I played was
called duty for years and shout out to
meskhi our boy mash key because he's
known him that long
I've not dude I've known for a while
call duty ghost you guys that's I couldn
t people in there and it would always
get racial yeah but but uh we we we
played that I didn't even know destiny
was a game I didn't know it was like
this big up-and-coming like Bungie
release I had no ideas the day of mess
key told me we were playing Call of Duty
psycho destiny destiny comes out today I
gotta go get that and I was like I wanna
check yeah I was like I need a new game
I went out and got that [ __ ] as soon as
I got two hours in I was like I'm not
playing call Dede again like this is my
fake cuz I love that that is long Jesus
to smooth this game Bungie so really
good but there see for me it's like when
I hear how much money they spent on
making the game that I'm in because when
Grand Theft Auto 5 came out and it was
role that stake out the game and all the
news about it and the guy like he
invested all this money whatever was
going on I heard how much money they
spent and when I played that game I was
like I was blown away anyone this is so
amazing
yeah with Michael the one with my house
and then
when I heard destiny spent equivalent
money same amount of money like that
they smell you know five hundred million
dollars I was like well this is gonna be
a great game mm-hmm and I gotta check it
out that's the reason why I checked it I
know what I liked about GTA is like you
do rent you can make you create your own
game like I would just take my sniper
rifle and then what see what cars would
come and I would snipe them through the
window dude their head would hit the
choppers no no I had two games I'll play
two two things I was on my own type of
game I would get a tank oh yeah and then
I would just like just kill people kill
people - the cops would come you get a
army no but my second one was like I
would try to get I would go to the
airport that's what I always do I go to
the airport steal the plane and then I
fly to the army base so I can steal a
fighter jet do that okay wait by the way
my favorite my favorite open-world game
is infamous like that I gotta tell you I
gotta tell you my Grand Theft Auto thing
that I do what I would like to do is I
would I get a bus I go to the comedy
store I sign up
oh wait I'll get a bus and I'll take it
to the freeway and I'll cut off a whole
leg oh then I'll let all of the cars
build up and I'll just plant c4 and then
I'll blow it if you played I still play
it every now and then they get this like
energy gun that you could like you know
I love that well I gotta say grand theft
was amazing for the high me because when
it was on 360 it felt like a next-gen
game yeah like the amount of detail and
graphics I was blown away by those who's
the guy heavy the trailer park Trevor
Trevor well I liked going there cuz it's
like a desolate place and I would go
into their gun shop and shoot the gun
owner
now we'll just run I would just try to
see how long cuz it you know I figure do
first person yeah like I was like way
out in the desert right person first
person too much you know was to like
steal a police car okay but then get
away and then put that police car in
your garage then you can go back to it
and now you have a police car yes
driving around a police car like that's
your regular car I tell you one thing
about those games I mean soundtracks are
amazing what I thought was amazing was
because I'm a nerd and I love certain
soundtracks but tangerine dream when
they did for there was a song for it
that sounded like tangerine dream and
they did five they actually got
tangerine dream to do this tell you one
last thing I did in GTA though I would
shoot people like near the mo Holland
you know like the rails but there was
like this this one patio where you could
jump over and they can't get to you oh
yeah so I would jump over the patio and
now it just always I would camp out
there mmm I start and then I would
sometimes jump out and then shoot more
cops okay my favorite okay another
favorite thing is doing G I love that
we're talking about this I like being
the black dude what's his name I mean
you know how you could buy like the shop
where you can like my favorite thing to
do is to like drive over the mountains
yeah yeah I like to go straight if I see
it on the map you just go I'm going
straight like I want to drive over the
mountains I'm gonna hit and then the car
would flip over to my favorite thing is
being the white guy and then walking but
like the black neighborhood
and just walk around because then if you
just stand by like because there's the
wall street with all the gang members
you just stand there they will just
eventually start [ __ ] with you
it's the funniest [ __ ] where we can pick
up hookers yeah of course I used to map
out like where they were would you how
try to get the nicest car it's a video
game I love with GTA when they online
you could [ __ ] with your friends your
friends would get on you'd be driving
around this huge city and you could just
throw [ __ ] out and shoot them through
Windows run them over
I'd be like where you at like I go Chris
I just mow him over with the car that
was the best part
when's the next grand theft drop and I'm
like yeah red dead and then after the
same kind of world yeah honey yeah the
first pass my favorite part was my
favorite oh my god like moment is like
you get to Mexico and like it's like
right over the like Rio Grande or
wherever and like the music comes in and
the gland scape changes to you that was
so cinematic it was but also the random
moments were great cuz everywhere I was
just walking around and like the forest
once just not doing any missions and
then a bear comes out of foe ya know
we're in the mountains paper - tiger but
there's games within the games you can
play darts you can go watch a movie
movie you can smoke weed and Grand Theft
Auto 5
there was there was like a side mission
where you had to smoke peyote and then
like you have to chase like Bigfoot it's
a secret mission to grant the thought of
light it's super funny alright guys well
let's call it there guys I was
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]